we're here in the city of her son in
southern Ukraine and this city spent
nearly nine months under Russian
occupation it was captured in the early
days of the war and wasn't liberated
until mid-november and when you walk
around the city you'll see a lot of
symbols like this
a yellow ribbon you'll also see
Ukrainian flags and these markings were
made by residents of her son well they
were living under Russian occupation
they say it was meant to send a message
to other ukrainians of solidarity and
resistance and also a message to the
Russians that their presence was not
wanted here and there are symbols like
this all throughout the city and what
began as a largely silent symbolic
protest soon evolved into a full-blown
underground resistance
Lilia alexandrova is a stay-at-home
mother of three but under Russian
occupation she took on a new job as a
member of the Ukrainian resistance
she began by secretly spraying these
Ukrainian flags and yellow ribbons
around her neighborhood in the middle of
the night
my hands were shaking and my heart was
pounding I was so nervous she says
before long she found the courage to
secretly we send information about the
Russians their activities and positions
to the Ukrainian military she used an
encrypted chat group set up by Ukrainian
I.T workers including Alex who asked us
to protect his identity
we have a lot of people who help the
resistance who were caught by the
Russians he says they were taken away we
don't know where they are for sure
[Music]
Alex and others helped to organize these
anti-russian protests in her son during
occupation and in November the Ukrainian
military used the coordinates provided
by residents to launch their
counter-offensive Ukraine retook control
of the Strategic Port City sparking
celebrations in the streets
organizers say their membership has now
swelled to more than 4 000 people and
while her son has been liberated they're
now working to support other areas
living under Russian occupation
Jeff Temple Global News in her son